this is another Fox News Alert one of
the advisors who has been with Donald
Trump since long before he became
president was awakened this morning by
FBI agents in Assault gear shouting at
him to open his door tonight Roger stone
is facing a seven count indictment
charging him with various crimes linked
to the release of hacked Democratic
Party emails during the 2016 campaign
chief intelligence correspondent
Catherine Herridge has the specifics
tonight good evening Catherine well
thank you Brennan good evening Roger
stone will be arraigned on Tuesday in
the DC federal court today he was
released on a $250,000 bond
leaving federal court in Florida a
defiant Roger stone waived the peace
sign like his old boss Richard Nixon as
boos and cheers rang out the longtime
political operative and friend of Donald
Trump said the special counsel
indictment is baseless and politically
motivated
there is no six hours earlier heavily
armed FBI agents raided Stone's Fort
Lauderdale home at the same time the
special counsel circulated the 24 page
seven count indictment that alleged
false statements witness tampering and
obstructing a congressional
investigation
that the special counsel's office
released a press release prior the seven
counts go to the heart of the Trump
campaign and allegations against its
most senior officials who go unnamed
quote a senior Trump campaign official
was directed to contact stone about any
additional releases and what other
damaging information organization one
which is WikiLeaks had regarding the
Clinton campaign stone thereafter told
the Trump campaign about potential
future releases of damaging material by
WikiLeaks the indictment does not accuse
stone of conspiring with WikiLeaks or
Russian agents instead it accuses stone
of lying to Congress about his WikiLeaks
contacts
the president tweeted greatest witch
hunt in the history of our country no
collusion his attorney Rudy Giuliani
said quote the indictment today is yet
again nothing more than another false
statement charge it doesn't allege
collusion seems like we're coming to an
end with the stone charges the special
counsel has either indicted convicted or
gotten guilty pleas for more than 30
people in businesses including former
insiders personal attorney michael cohen
national security adviser Mike Flynn and
campaign chairman Paul Manafort stones a
former business partner this connection
to the integrity of our elections is
obviously something we'd have to get the
truth to battle 20 months into the
special counsel appointment none of the
publicly prosecuted cases have alleged
coordination between the Russian
government and Trump campaign Special
Counsel Muller's washington-based grand
jury was recently granted an extension
for at least another six months to
continue its work Brett Catherine thank
you